und es ist ein haus mit zwei
schrecklichen schicksal gestern
nachmittag wurde die polizei riegelsberg
zu einem notfall gerufen ein streit soll
eskaliert seien leider nicht das erste
mal dass dies mit einem todesopfer in
diesem haus geändert hat bilder des
grauens auf dem autobahnparkplatz
hochwald ost an der a1 in richtung trier
rettungskräfte entdeckten diesen
brennenden auto eine leiche vermutlich
einen mann und zwar wahrscheinlich jeder
der eine stunde zuvor im 60 kilometer
entfernten riegelsberg einen
polizeieinsatz ausgelöst hatte dort
finden die beamten eine schwer verletzte
frau
ihr ehemann war mit dem pkw geflüchtet
kurios genau dieses haus machte schon im
jahr 2008 schlagzeilen
er stach jedoch ein jugendlicher seinen
vater neun jahre später war der selbe
mann eine rohrbombe vor das haus und
verschanzte sich dort nach angaben der
polizei haben diese bizarren fälle und
die aktuellen ereignisse jedoch nichts
miteinander zu tun wie nun zugeschaltet
reporter thomas müller präsentiert und
passgenau soll sich da gestern
abgespielt haben
ja also gestern abend gegen 17 uhr wurde
die polizei alarmiert
familiendrama hier 39-jährige mann 37
jährigen frau soll mit beil auf sie
eingeschlagen haben die frau wurde dann
später schwer verletzt hier im haus
gefunden und ist jetzt im krankenhaus
zum gesundheitszustand machte die
polizei derzeit noch keine angaben ja
und bei der leiche wie was gerade
gesehen haben handelt es sich
wahrscheinlich um den ehemann der 60
kilometer entfernt in seinem wagen
verbrannt ist
gehen dank thomas müller für diese neuen
details dankeschön